oh great well darn XP during the session
is first time speaking about analyzing
algorithms that real-world bit thank you
um when I was a chair of soda about 10
years ago of course what makes mistakes
and they're people who always remind you
of your mistakes people here who love to
remind me of mistakes um so one mistake
people maybe you forgot him but i'll
mention it was i actually put in the
same session papers on game theory and
unique games you know right which to it
you know just sort of veena but the
person who scheduled these two talks
together did something very similar here
so i'm going to be talking very all
right so I you still did you organizes
what you're not supposed to do but it's
all to myself so that's sort of okay all
right anyway no it's nice to be a no
it's very nice to me at this workshop
with such a diverse set of topics
intermingles and I think it's great and
so I'm going to talk about analyzing
algorithms on real world data so I'm
going to talk about not really talking
about theory i'm talking about some
experiences of working on some real
world problems and trying to draw some
generalizations and tell some stories
and i'll make some you know statements
that may or may not be true you know i
think we're true but of course they're
only backed up by my experiences and
happy to have discussions during the
talk and you know to try to think start
to think about the point is to think
about what are we doing here okay so
what I'm going to just say there's some
is an area that's you know becoming sort
of somewhat defined that a lot of people
do that's called out girl engineering
which is and this is you know you've
designed your better algorithm then you
prove some theorems about shortest path
or your TSP your cots or something and
now you go and you try to implement it
right so I mean this isn't algum
engineering is broader than this but the
way I think about doing it is off you
know you've done some theory and now you
want to try to verify as you go off you
implement the algorithm you you generate
some data you might be some random data
like offer mentioned you know random you
got to be careful with random data but
you generate some good random data those
instances out there
in the world right if you want to if you
have a new tsp algorithm or a new cut
algorithm there's data out there so you
run on the data that everyone else is
run on and so uh but I just want to say
this is not the main focus of this talk
all right so I'm not insulting this I
only insult the organizers I'm not
insulting this and myself no but um i'm
not i just want say this is not what I'm
talking about okay what I really want to
talk about is when you're confronted
with a real with some real-world
problems okay yeah whether it's best
well both I mean either one right but I
think when people you mean when people
talk about algorithm engineering and
then oh no only fast I mean fast or
usually you can show with either the
speed or you're concerned with not
necessarily correct but the Yak but if
it's if it's an NPR problem you might be
concerned with the accuracy of your
solution either both aspects you want to
find out by well you probably yes you
want to find out experimentally how fast
it tends to run with it and you also
want to see I I mean typically right
you've proved something some
approximation ratio and that's a
worst-case right so you want to
understand what's going on on average
okay anyway I just want to say that sort
of that's sort of often that's what you
think about I think that's most of the
talks on you know more applied stuff
that I say but I want to think more
about dealing with some real-world
problems and talk about some experiences
and draw some channelization so the to
experience to experiences that I want to
focus on that I've had that I'll draw
these generations from one is working
with scheduling Google's data centers
and the other is managing the
maintenance of the US nuclear weapons
stockpile and yes that should scare you
that somehow I'm involved in I don't
know which one should scare you more
right anyway these are these are two
these are two things I've been i'll talk
more about details i want to sort of
talk high level for a few minutes and
then talk about details so i think the
high level questions I want to think
about is you know with when you
confronted with a real problem with a
real problem the things you have to
think about is one is you know how do
you provide what's a good solution right
we don't necessarily
what the optimal solution is right we
don't so we can't necessarily compared
to that okay how do you how do you test
and evaluate right so you don't have a
very well-defined situation here right
now right like these two examples we
don't have a perfect model of them so
the question of testing your algorithms
and evaluating which algorithms are
better is not so not so well defined and
the other question also that I like to
think about and really you know I right
what is what's the value of theory it's
really I really what really is why am I
doing this right that's sort of what I'm
really thinking about but right the
generalization of that is you know
what's the value theory in this applied
world why should people who are trained
in theory be working on these problems
as opposed to someone else there are in
addition to someone else okay so let me
just talk a little bit about each of
these in general right you know so when
you talk about providing a good solution
right i mean the the things you're
confronted with is you know you should
you have some some current data that
you're working with right like maybe
what's happening today or what happened
last year so you should be designing
algorithms that work for this but of
course the interesting thing is that you
should come up with solutions that work
continue to work into the foreseeable
future so you need some way to model how
this is likely to change or how the
problems likely to get harder in the
future and so you need to develop such a
model and the other issue which is
non-trivial is you also need to be able
to convince people running your solution
the people who are going to actually run
your solution that it is a good solution
and so people who don't necessarily
theorems or don't actually believe that
you know anything right so I don't
really have anything brilliant to say
about this just just an observation that
I forget every time I do this and then
I'm reminded that you know the it's
important one is just to build
relationships with people you're working
with and also to be able to explain what
you're doing okay and this is often more
than half the battle to actually get
something implemented okay alright so
that's and how do you test and evaluate
right so you demonstrate good
performance on the current data
demonstrate into protected future now
this is I think this is actually
very very challenging and maybe maybe
they'll be other talks at this workshop
maybe but there'll be some talk about
this like what what is a model of the
current data like you know we can say
okay I have a data set you know this is
it right and I can try to solve it and I
can solve it correctly or run in 10
seconds or be five percent more more
fish but what we really need is we need
to build a model of what the current
data is that we can then generalize and
analyze and try to predict and this is
really hard and I think people
underestimate this in practice at least
people think oh yeah we can we can model
our data at least let me let me say this
again it really this is me personally I
failed miserably doing this so it will
come up later but I can just tell you
something that I don't know how to solve
so you can take take take so take
Google's data centers take some number
of them I don't you know I don't know I
think the number they have is a secret
so take some number then we're going to
say 50 that's just a made-up number and
now take I don't know you know take take
three months right so now you have you
know 5,000 roughly days of data on data
centers right and that takes them to
look at them you know you can record and
we'll see this more in a minute you know
we get to the problem you can record so
you know how many jobs there are and
what their some distributions on their
processing times right so these like
five thousand different points and now
try to just find some that are similar
right that's really hard that sounds
like it should be easy right you know
you can do some statistics you can do
some simple machine learning I mean
maybe there's more complicated machine
learning that can be done oh no but try
to say you know this this data center on
this day is similar to the state of the
center in this way right similar so you
can think about reproducible experiments
that's a really hard problem I think
trying to understand when two datasets
when to complicate data sense are
similar is something I just want to I
don't know how to solve it I just like
to encourage people here to you know
think about that right we have our
simple models right about
this and some theory on this but to
really look at it so it's actually
useful for reproducible experiments very
hard okay and actually because of this
and again this is something that people
I think who even work on the practice of
them forget because you can't predict
the future you have to think worst case
right you really I think it's important
to have again not not that everything is
just worst case and you take your
approximation ratios and they're all
correct and they all are correct
accuracy but you need to be if you're
not thinking about performing well on
something worse case or really bad case
data then this fact that you don't know
how to predict the future is going to
come up and hurt you yep so to
understand similarity of data sets where
you meet someone I respect to event and
algorithm like running time of
performance open up I was just looking
at I'll come to this in a minute I
joined you know I wanted two tests
algorithms on similar wants to say two
different algorithms on similar data
sets right so I want to say this data
set is like this data set other words it
has roughly the same number of jobs the
jobs have the same time I'm just looking
at data the statement I made had none do
with algorithms the statement was I just
want to understand this data set and
this data set are similar how do I
respect what makes similar of its
victims well so right so I mean I'll
define the data a little better you know
but i was looking at number of jobs and
running times of jobs and something
about the distribution over time of jobs
and just try to look for similarity
measures okay later way of phrasing late
that sort of saying you'd like to
understand something about what the
distribution of your current data is so
you can say what the distribution that
future data is likely to be like that
would be great yeah I think that's
really I mean you probably experienced
this too I think that's really hard a
lot harder than people think it is
Sanjeev is making it we cannot estimate
dissolution we cannot do estimate
density estimation that's too hard so we
have to take a limited aspect of the
living an aspect is how we can affect
our algorithms and I guess that's what
sanjeev was your friend in fact want to
talk about similarity similarity with
respect to some goal that you respect to
this goal they will behave similarly
that's why I think that maybe maybe I
think not more jobs is relevant to the
effectiveness of biographies but there
is some goal will speak to which any
final singularity because I cannot talk
about similarity between two
institutions get I kept destination I
can't estimate but this was real
datasets this wasn't distributions this
was I mean I think it's liquid David I
want to build a model I want to
understand right right okay Fahrenheit
right so I'm assuming distribution right
but figure out what the distribution is
it's hard I think okay at least all
agreeing maybe not saying it right okay
um okay and then what is just let me
just make this you know what's the
what's the sort of non-obvious value of
the theory right one is one is modeling
right I think we have the right training
to understand that if you want to reason
about algorithms you have to come up
with a simple enough model that lets you
reason about algorithms okay and this is
just something maybe that we all
understand but a lot of people don't you
know you wanted you want to design
algorithms again they're not tailored to
the particular data understand
worst-case behavior also but we want to
be flexible enough to use properties of
algorithms not just to be focused on our
worst case analysis of course everyone's
here for this week for that purpose so
you're going to say that in you know we
can learn more general lessons okay let
me let me let me talk about a couple of
concrete instances and make these points
somewhat okay so so let me again talk
briefly about this experience with
scheduling a data center right so this
is a this just you know it's obviously
an important problem lots of companies
run large data centers they have huge
costs they run a lot of
or you want to maintain them efficiently
I'm going to talk about Google but of
course many other companies and
governments have the same problem and
this is some work I did at Google with
Monica hen's egg araneta an erratum and
a [ __ ] a few years ago okay all right
so let me try to what what what kind of
environment so and what we're talking
about is you know there are these data
centers and work comes into the data
centers and you have to decide which
machine the work goes on that's the
basic problem we're looking at okay so
work is so you're thinking about you
know many many jobs are coming are
coming in right all kind all kinds of
things from you know the things if your
google you're running search and you're
running mail and you're running those
kind of things to you know to
experiments that people are running you
know to whatever else to different male
processes so there's lot so it's a very
diverse set of input okay so users are
submitting jobs to this environment a
job consists of a sequence of a set of
tasks with jobs can be decomposed and
we're going to be talking about
scheduling tasks you have mix of
long-running and short running jobs you
have a mix of user facing and back-end
jobs and you mix of high priority and
low priority jobs okay again i'm not the
point of this talk isn't to get it every
detail of this and just but sort of give
you an idea of the sort of the type of a
probe more to get an idea of the type of
approach we took at how we thought about
it okay so we can think about something
called the data center which has
thousands of machines we can think of
we'll think of some time period will
think of our time period is a day long
enough to have say hundreds of thousands
of tasks okay okay and the goal is you
want to evaluate the performance of
super close want to schedule a better so
in evaluating performance of many
different scheduling algorithms on a
large data center and compare somehow
you might improve things like cell
utilization overall productivity energy
consumption it's a little vague you'll
get more more detailed of course when
you deal with these real problems often
the people telling you the objectives
are vague and often tell you competing
objective so that's one of the
challenges is to try to figure out what
you really need to do okay in the meadow
go like i said is how do you really
carry out such an experiment okay so
actually when you start to see there's
lasting a lot of goals you might have
these are sort of the tip
goal scheduling goals you know these are
sort of standard types of things and
people want all of these right they want
throughput number process tasks and
you've got a total time you can think
about useful work preemptions right so
jobs being preempted by the system
preemption can be a waste of time
because you have to preempt things you
have to do something some kind of
context switch state we're know about
the queue size right so they can look at
the queue size queues accused building
up cues of jobs or bad talk about energy
consumption right the amounts of
electricity used by these data centers
and often will come back this
fragmentation sort of thinking about how
many machines you use and don't you so
all these things are sort of in play oh
they're not all opposed to each other by
me most of these sort of most of these
are actually moving in this in this in
the same direction right I mean you know
energy can say viously energy
consumption if you shut the data centers
down you minimize so that's that's going
in a different direction is this
probably the data or of the after after
you run the algorithm these are
objective functions of the algorithm yes
right but but you changed all of them
and these promise you it's not a
parameter the data this is not a primer
the data no right this is this is to
measure right the quality of the
algorithm right you gonna be able you
want want to be able to measure how well
you're doing okay all right so the thing
is I want to focus on now is sort of an
increased throughput talk about machine
fragmentation and again we'll see why
outside of a lineman increasing the
number of unused machines and we'll see
why that's important in a minute I mean
it's basically for power savings and
growth and we'll see why that's
important in a minute okay so what do we
do just to go the brief methodology
right so you can connect could collect
data from google data centers they keep
traces right so it's a whole thing of
what data should you collect but just
list some things that we collected in a
minute then you build a model of a
scheduling system right so you can sort
of simulate things you can experiment
with various algorithms okay all right
so one thing is just how to get at
what's important so again this takes you
know this takes some some just work with
the data but machines basically can be
abstracted to some amount of disk memory
and CPU now the machines have other
features but they all seem to be second
order in terms of scheduling system and
then when you think of again the jobs in
their system have a lot of different
parameters but too abstract to a model
that we can reason about jobs are a set
of tasks which have some kind of demand
for CPU disk memory they have some
precedence relationship with each other
they have some priority there's etc but
these are really the important ones they
are processing times again there's a
long list of other possible constraints
but for purpose remodeling we can ignore
those all right and then what we can do
is build a simulator which replays say
day of scheduling using different
algorithms okay and so we use data
gathered from extent they have these
checkpoint files that get the data we
want to camp by the scheduling system at
which wich Jobs ran on which machines
and what we actually did is tried 11
different algorithms in the in the
simulator so ultimately you get to this
you decide what data you want to use and
then we can experiment with a bunch of
different algorithms okay the way sorry
well I'm going to come to that you mean
how do we how do we know that the
simulator is correctly simulating sorry
are you asking are you asking how do we
evaluate the choices of how to
assimilate or how do we value it
validate the conclusions how do you know
the simulator was natural give you an
accurate model of the system you were
simulated so so so we actually sold so
there's there is a real scheduling
system we actually did some engineering
of the scheduling system to see what you
what what data actually matters in the
decisions and we looked at things that
we're actually you know some things like
processing time matters in every
decision some features have a very small
impact on the decision Oh on the
decisions made if you look at the actual
the maybe an algorithm that says you
know if X is less than Y and then you
look at that and you see that part of
the code is actually only used you know
one one-thousandth of one percent of the
time so we didn't put that into our
simulator of course then in the end
there's going to be the question of ok
we're going to come with up with some
conclusions from the simulator how do we
know that those are look you have to
make the connection back which will come
to ok alrighty way so sort of the guts
of a scheduling decision is given a task
you need to choose a machine so
basically you need to come up with some
way to score so you have a task there's
some machines maybe it just can't run on
right because it doesn't have the right
you know code on there or the data is
not in the right place or something and
we're going to compute some kind of
score and we're going to sign the task
the lowest scoring machine okay and
what's interesting about this is sort of
the multi-dimensional nature of fitting
a job on to a machine okay so what are
what our decisions were based on right
so so we want to say after you put a job
on a machine you know what do you look
at so we looked at what sort of how full
is the machine after you would put the
job on it okay so this is this is the
data we're going to use in our
algorithms so we can look at this for
ram cpu and dis you can say suppose I
were to schedule this job on this
machine you know in addition to the
other stuff that's on there how much how
much free space would there still be as
a percentage okay obviously if you can't
fit it you know you don't you don't put
that in and you don't consider it okay
and actually what we did is we went
through a whole bunch of different
algorithms that are sort of right this
is like a this is a multi-dimensional
bin packing problem and so we worked
with sort of the standard types of bin
packing algorithms like some version of
best fit right place the job on the
machine with the smallest available hole
now of course hole is its
multidimensional right if it's
one-dimensional is clear with the
smallest hole is if it's
multidimensional it's not clear you
tried different ways of scoring it but
you know you could take sums or sums of
squares or exponential we could consider
ram and cpu again the points we tried a
lot of different things and there's
reasons to try some of these and not
others and not get into all these
decisions you talk about a first fit
right so you place it either on the just
a machine that it fits on that has the
smallest ID
or you can think about a random fit you
can think about worst fit right which is
load balancing basically right so worst
fit was actually what had been done
before we started working on this right
so worst fit sounds bad right but but
its its load balancing okay talk about
random you know what sum of squares
which i think is actually nice algorithm
and you may be familiar with it let me
just mention it because because I think
it's a nice album to think about so
right so sum of squares is is used for
one dimensional bin packing and you can
prove various things about it being
optimal under certain discrete
distributions right the idea what the
what sum of squares does is it tries to
create with a diverse set of free
machines in other words right and and
some sense this is this is this is I did
call this worst-case thinking right you
don't know what's going to come in the
future right so you'd like is that you
know some machines are full and some are
ten percent full and some are twenty
percent fall somewhere thirty percent
full say you know and some are are
completely empty okay so it's actually a
good way to do this and so you can work
out the details which mail do an
interest of time right of just how you
do some multiple multiple dimensions but
it's exactly what you think you can you
bucket the machines right based on what
they look like what percentage of free
ram they have what percentage of free
CPU they have what percentage are free
this they have rights you can bucket the
machines and now you take the set your
score is the sum of the the sum of the
squares of the bucket sizes right so
this is gonna because you're taking the
sum of the squares it's going to tend to
ideally you know as we minimized when it
when when it's roughly equal okay and I
of course they're different variants of
this but this was enough this was one
variant we considered okay all right so
we had these different algorithms I'll
mention actually one thing is that this
this actually is a slightly more
complicated algorithm to code up the
best fit or first fit and that actually
in the end was was a bit of a problem
just because right this is it's not a
problem in all algorithms from but this
is being used in a real system we have
to make you need the scheduling system s
to work very fast right that's a
constraint right you have to make your
decisions quickly and so
actually believe that this could have
been done right but it presented
challenges the system's level all right
now how do you evaluate these algorithms
so now you have your algorithms you have
your your simulation data you run your
simulations actually the first thing
that happened is that we concluded that
every algorithm was algorithms don't
matter every algorithm is the same ok
and then why was that right the reason
is that we had it we had some trace of
jobs good jobs that ran okay we didn't
have jobs that didn't run right and so
so basically if you ran all your jobs
and you're under loaded you know then
algorithms are going to do reasonably
well right if the system is liver
systems lightly loaded and you're just
trying to you just you know it ran
everything you know you changed
something a little bit still runs
everything okay I didn't have the system
was overloaded you didn't know which
jobs it didn't run and so we weren't
able to distinguish between algorithms
because we only had we only had a trace
of the things that succeeded and not the
things that didn't succeed okay so this
was something we had to think about and
this led us I mean this goes beyond this
problems there's also it's very specific
to what ran it specific to the
particular data set okay so when we
thought about evaluating it right of
course you want to be able to
distinguish between algorithms and you
want to do well as data center load
increases okay so actually what we did
is again it's not that deep but it
worked is so you want to you want to
think about how this going to happen as
it scales into the future right so you
can either scale up the number of jobs
or equivalently you could scale down the
number of machines and we actually
scaled down the number of machines the
main reason being it's sort of it's
easier right you don't have to make
predictions about I mean you can rant
randomly deleting machines somehow seems
a little more principled than making up
what work is going to come in the future
although neither one is perfectly
modeling future but so now you can say
so now our metric is throughput so now
we can let T of X be the number of jobs
completed so if on the data set if we
used only X percent of the machines in a
data center okay and now you can
evaluate
an algorithm by looking at its T of X
values okay and whatever you can choose
we here's the ones that are going to
look at again this is from
experimentation and the same reasoning
applies to other metrics anyway so
here's the point and here's how we
analyze the algorithms so this is each
algorithm this is the percentage of
machines you have and what you see is
that the and this is somewhat a feature
of the data but it's also you know that
so when you have all the machines you
can see all the algorithms are doing the
same and again if they're off by a
couple is just some point corner case in
the simulation that we're in so careful
about but what happens is at some point
is you start taking away machines the
algorithms start to die right and
different algorithms die at different
times so like if you look at this
algorithm here which is load balancing
you know when you get down to
eighty-seven percent of the machines
it's only running you know it's running
less than half the jobs right on the
other hand if you go to some other out
you know like best fit and you get down
to eighty-seven percent of the machines
it's still running a you know eighty
percent of the jobs right and so by
looking at basically how many how many
machines can you delete and still
maintain you know before the performance
starts to fall out off you get an idea
of which algorithms are better so the
better algorithms have bigger numbers
you know going up as high as we can
actually I think was sort of again it's
not I mean it's just sort of looking at
how things go out syntactically but this
is one of the things that actually took
quite a while to come upon this as the
way of evaluating algorithms and this
this turned out to help us make some
good decisions okay so it's sort of a
nest so so you can think of it as
looking into the future right because if
you think about it you know having
eighty percent of the machines is sort
of like having twenty percent more work
and so you know when we you know okay so
right now everything looks the same but
we have twenty percent more work you
know this algorithm is doing a lot
better than this algorithm right and so
this is sort of saying you know how far
in the future and roughly equivalent how
far in the future can we go before you
know job loads increase before we have
to you buy more machines
ok and so let me go quickly through this
just to say you can know it can graph
this and it's just as just grabbed so
this you can look at the graphs again
it's not clear what it's that's a whole
table and graphs what should you take
right so we look at a very kind of
variety of things you look at you know
how many times an algorithm wins but
that may not even be the times you can
you might really care about how many
times it comes close to winning or we
might only really care about you know we
don't want to be you know our data set
had things at twenty percent maybe we
didn't care maybe we only want to look
at the eighty ninety percent range and
so we did a bunch of different you know
we just tried to be robust by looking at
a bunch of different statistics on this
we looked at other metrics right this
was just throughput you can look at
useful work but the same methodology the
point is we applied the same methodology
to use for work you get some conclusions
among the I'm happy to talk more about
the algorithms offline and people are
you know interested anyway just in the
end just case you have a data center
that you're scheduling tomorrow best fit
seem to actually be the best like your
best friend in sum of squares seem to
really be the two winners and I think
she wound up going with something called
we wound up going with best but the load
balancing actually seem to do quite
poorly in our metrics and again this is
what I said in the beginning right so
you would like to okay so so so you have
your simulation right and now you want
to say well k and maybe like was it like
ken asked right you know maybe the
simulation was bogus right maybe I
wasn't simulating real data so you
really want to run it on real data
centers okay this also is really hard
now that data centers maybe or maybe one
of the hardest things you can imagine to
try to really run things on because you
know their side effects right so you
can't just it's not even clear how you
run the same load through a data center
you know twice like replete you can't
really replay a day and that was this
idea of trying to find well maybe I
could find two data centers that I can
have a model that I predict that you
know this data center on Monday in this
data center on Wednesday are going to
get the same input so then maybe I could
run two different algorithms and compare
didn't work we just couldn't do that so
we sort of had a go on a little bit of
faith actually in the end because we
really couldn't sign you know sort of in
a way that would call scientifically
prove that the simulation mattered okay
i just mentioned that also energy was
was part of this you mentioned some i'm
very interested in scheduling to reduce
energy and so actually we did just
mention we did think about that and so
you know how do these machines consume
power they have a you know there's a
model for this right it's not it's the
model is that between fifty one-hundred
percent utilization their power they use
is linear in the load at zero percent
you can turn it off in between 0 and 50
power usage is inefficient so what you
want to do is schedule so that you don't
have you know but you're not between
zero at zero or you're between 50 and
100 you're not between 0 and 50 i
actually best fit is actually works with
this rate best pretends to do this if
you think about the way best fit works
right so anyway we'll go through this
best fit that tends to do that too okay
um so maybe i guess i have two minutes
one minute so this is another important
problem two minutes let me let me give
you the two minute summary of this so
anyway so that was the work of google
something else worked with was
scheduling nuclear weapons main and so
i'll just tell you what the problem is
in two minutes in Texas there's a plant
that all nuclear weapons have to go
through every so often to be maintained
okay and it's actually a very it's
another it's a it's a different it's
very different scheduling problem right
you're not make you're not doing things
on the second you're doing things on the
scale of hours and days and you have you
know your jobs multiple tasks and they
each a particular job is like you know
taking some piece of a weapon and
opening it up and you know taking out
all the screws and rebuilding it or
something so the deterrent facilities
and certain workers there's a lot of fun
constraints some of which I'm not
allowed to know like you know these two
weapons in the same room will blow up
you got to respect that and the goal
here was to see if you have enough
resources to schedule everything that
needs to be scheduled in the next in the
next months or a year actually and it's
okay so the just to have a nice little
nugget of it the message
here was actually interesting was that
it's a huge integer program today that
you can't solve okay but so what are you
doing you can solve each program you saw
the LP even that's hard but with enough
work you could solve it too now you want
to round it who knows how to round it
right we know how to round linear
programs and we actually used a nice
idea from that was completely came up
with from theory which is from work on
average see if you've done it if you've
read any papers on average completion
time scheduling that aren't Pete asses
in the last 20 years they use something
called alpha points to figure how to
schedule which is just an idea from dumb
eunice's in theory you take a relaxation
you look at where is the earliest
percentage at which something finishes
and you schedule things in that order
okay and using this framework you prove
approximation ratios for these average
completion time purely combinatorial
purely useless problems and it turns out
that this is what worked in this
environment and the interesting thing
was that the reason it worked is sort of
that what does this do so you can
because it has this feature there's this
feature of these algorithms that they
take one relaxation like one linear
program and they can generate many
schedules because turns out you can try
different values of alpha the theory
idea was that you use random alpha use a
random alpha that's where you get the
proofs from of course you can simulate
if you're going to pick a random alpha
you can try them all and pick the best
alpha then it turns out that in practice
this idea of choosing the best alpha is
what works in this problem because it
allows them to solve one expensive LP
and then very quickly generate a lot of
schedules okay and that's why even as we
go forward your nuclear weapons are safe
okay anyway so i'll just mention that
you know the uncertainty time I no
certainty in the data actually this
plant in the 90s was used for
disarmament and the 2000s was used much
less for just like the nature of the
work change based on politics right
that's really like how the hell do you
model politics right we all know right
that's we all know that's really hard
right and just seen that so but that's
exactly why you want to be resilient you
know your algorithm should work for both
you know things that happen you know for
an uncertain future and the
future here part of the uncertain future
actually came from politics because part
of what this plant does is disarmament
and disarm it is is you know not
something we can predict how it's going
to go so anyway this this helped out we
were able to generate more efficient use
of their plant by like five to ten
percent using using these ideas okay so
anyway that's so anyway you know so I
was probably a little rambling a little
ideas but what I want out what I hope is
that you know just to start a
conversation hopefully this week people
thinking about you know how do you how
do you perform experience experiments
how do you model this idea of you know
modeling the data again as was pointed
out you're really modeling so you can
say something about algorithms you know
how do you do that and happy to talk
more about it thank you all right a few
minutes for questions so I was expecting
this that you with the direction you are
going and would use a machine learn
right so the classifier here or whatever
right the learning object that is what
some particular thing you know whatever
q whatever something that's a function
of the album so the file an algorithm
and the number is what you're trying to
understand and try to learn features
which boosts them something
yeah I guess I mean we didn't know we
didn't we didn't try I mean this was a
few years ago you know maybe I would go
back and and and and and try that but
but um you know there's also something
of that you know you're ultimately
writing in this case reading operating
systems code right and so I mean there's
the scheduling system right I mean some
level it's I mean what's a operating
system it's maybe it's not the UNIX
thing but you're up you're writing code
that's going to sched I mean not the
simulator but the ultimate what the
ultimate output of this is some code it
has to run very fast right and be very
simple scheduling maybe not the nuclear
me I say no no I'm talking about the the
data centers write the data centers a
job comes in you got to assign it to a
machine I mean we're not we're talking
about that the level of you know second
maybe you have it most right to make the
decision may be less so you do have the
feature that the algorithm that you come
up with needs to be simple enough to be
implemented right so it's it's not clear
again it is something that one could I
drown all fine second it yeah that is a
point in the whole point of machine
learning type approaches is that you
spend a long time learning the function
and then it executes very fast yeah so
right so it is I that is a good idea i
mean that you know i said we just didn't
do it is about something very related to
that um you know of course if the jobs
are short you can't afford much time but
for the long jobs will surely come in as
well every once in a while somebody a
blue ones that were you know sweet cpu
week experiment where every component of
the experiment runs four hours for those
you could actually afford having a
closer look at them and this might be
very much worthwhile so what's your
intuition is it important to have a
uniform level of scrutiny and
making all the jobs that come in might
they actually be benefit in being more
careful about the longer jobs you know
what one could one could do that and in
fact there are in the Google ecosystem
there are systems that you know there
are things that do that actually right
so and most of most of the I mean the
most of all jobs are so long they sort
of you're right they just take up space
and then your your decision and you know
your med the metrics that the level
we're looking at it the metrics are
coming from a lot of Metro coming from
short jobs right because you have many
more of them I do think that this war
machine learning approach is very
promising here I think it's especially
promising if you have a mix of very
short jobs which probably doesn't really
matter where you put them at all
actually and very long jobs where you
have very few choices and everything in
between right so I think that's exactly
where a learned model could make a lot
of sense yeah and a model that would
separate those two things out probably
need schedule did they work on the data
centers or the other word inspire any
theory work did you go back and rethink
some theory because of your um so the
the the second one definitely you we
used at it led to that like have some
work on using alpha points for problems
with deadlines which hadn't thought
about before but it did lead to thinking
of an expansion of what you know that
one it led to realizing that alpha
points had more uses than we thought of
at first I mean we I couldn't that one I
couldn't prove anything about I mean the
real problem is so complicated you have
a theorem about their problem but it did
lead to realizing that there was a
larger scope of problems that applied to
I mean the data center where you could
say you know multi do I mean people have
been working on multi-dimensional
packing problems
so although you know so I have thought
about although i don't have anything
salt I don't have anything conclusive
you know to tell you but it but it did
lead to thinking more about
multi-dimensional online
multi-dimensional packing which is what
the problem is I had to I himself a
speed and some of us carrots are very
deep on trying then what I was moving to
is so the the implementation was was
best fat was best fat summer squares
they perform very close sum of squares
that sum of squares was harder to
implement and the scheduling decisions
took longer I'm not sure if one worked
hard enough they couldn't have been it
couldn't been implanted better but it
actually you know if it takes long
enough then you start to the system
queue starts to build up right if you
can't make the decision fast enough the
queue just starts to grow and that you
know that could happen if you're close
to that you could be worried that's
going to happen so that was a reason not
to not to do that okay let's take a
cliff again
now we've got a coffee